every now and again someone in the
government gets asked a good question I
would say Fox News is Peter Ducey is
basically the the rare the rarest of the
rare at the moment uh here he is at the
White House asking black lesbian press
secretary Karin John Pierre when the
White House will delete their Twitter
because obviously it's run by this crazy
white supremacist mean capitalist dude
who's into Republicans or something and
he's releasing information we can't have
that so why is the White House on this
thing on another subject
when are you guys going to delete the
White House Twitter account
why would we do that well you're saying
that you're keeping an eye on Twitter
because it might not be a suitable
platform so why use it look
I want to be very clear here the
president has always said and he has
been very very clear in his belief that
it is important of social media
platforms to continue to take steps to
reduce hate speech and misinformation
and he'll we'll continue to say that
Joe Biden all right all right I was
going to be against the voice I was
going to be a little mean to Joe Biden
I'm going to try to be a little nicer
than I was about to be
um Joe or guys pulling Joe strings
nobody gives an F what you think about
hate speech there's no such thing as
hate speech we have the Supreme Court
which has decided that you are allowed
to say mean things about people the
government has no right to tell a tech
company or a shoe store or a barber what
is allowed to be said in their stores
okay you guys have violated the first
amendment that is obvious and you're
back on your heels but nobody cares it
doesn't matter Karin Jean-Pierre that
Joe Biden has made it clear that big
Tech should do this no it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter you are yelling in a
void it does not matter now I get it
there are bad people out there and Bad
actors out there and you can place
people at Twitter like Jim Baker who can
do bad things but in the way that our
system works or is or at least purports
to work or I believe has some pieces of
it that still work it does not matter
about hate speech people say mean things
to me on Twitter they did just the past
this weekend people did say mean things
to me I interviewed baby Netanyahu from
Israel we're going to get to that in a
second you know if you say anything
about Israel these whack-a-doodle all
Anonymous crazy people come out and say
horrible things they do I did not call
for anyone to be banned I blocked a
couple people that's how it is anyway
what this is all
about really is that they're losing the
narrative uh so of course what are they
going to say about the hunter Biden
story well it's not even a real story
that's what they're going to try to say
now even though we all know something is
rotten in the state of Denmark
you had said I think six or so days ago
that the White House was watching
um closely the situation at Twitter
after Elon musk's ownership of it with
respect to misinformation and because
these files were released
um on the basis of you know
hack materials Clause at Twitter
decisions were made to censor reporting
leading up to the election my question
was is it the White House view that
these decisions were made appropriately
in light of what has come out which
Decisions by whom by Twitter by Twitter
on okay so look
we see this as a an interesting or a
coincidence if I may that uh that he
would so haphazardly uh Twitter was so
haphazardly pushed this distraction uh
that is a that is a full of old news if
you think
he's horrible she makes Jen Saki
look like Margaret Thatcher she really
does uh this is old news this is a
distraction
um the world's richest man buying the
tech company to now show the world that
the government was coordinating to
silence dissent on at least the hunter
Biden laptop story and as I said earlier
I think we're going to find out a whole
bunch more like way more when it comes
to covid and why Dr Robert Malone and
Peter McCullough were banned from
Twitter